[Music]
Halloween is directed by David Gordon
Green and stars once again Jamie Lee
Curtis reprising her role as a Laurie
Strode this is the official sequel to
the first film it was directed by John
Carpenter
it's retconning every single film in
between the two so Halloween two never
happened Halloween h2o never happened
Halloween resurrection never happened
which I kind of already assumed that
anyway so as Michael Myers is being
transported to a new facility the bus
crashes letting himself and all the
other patients escape Laurie Strode has
been preparing for this night for the
past 40 years she has a stockpile of
guns and a home filled with traps and
she is ready to finally destroy Michael
Myers once and for all I have not been
this excited for a new movie this year
since Mission Impossible fall out I was
so ready for this movie I'm such a
massive fan of the Halloween films I
mean I own all of them on blu-ray even
the crappy ones I mean granted I have a
collection okay but like I'm the type of
guy who seeked
out the producers cut of the Paul Rudd
one because I wanted to see if it was
any better than the original and it is
but like that's the level of fandom I'm
at here like the the Halloween films
they kind of mean something to me and I
think I go into them a little bit more
critical than perhaps your average fan
or just once a horror movie and wants to
see Michael Myers kill some people if
that's all you want you're gonna be
totally happy but I was disappointed in
this movie very disappointed it's not a
bad film I certainly do not hate this
film I think the word is frustrated I'm
just very frustrated because there are
shades of greatness throughout this film
and we'll talk about those first Jamie
Lee Curtis provides all of the best
elements of this movie her portrayal of
Laurie Strode now is fierce badass but
most of all believable because when you
go through a traumatic experience in
life like what she went through
you become very paranoid you start to
over prepare because you don't want that
to ever happen to you or any of your
loved ones again so I totally bought
into what she has now become as this
very quiet
a secluded woman who has like a gate
around her house and all these secret
hideaways in the house because she is
basically planning for the inevitable
escape of Myers because she recognizes
that he is more than human and she still
believes in the boogeyman after having
experienced him in the first film it
wasn't just that I liked seeing Jamie
Lee Curtis back in Halloween film though
they really did handle that storyline
very well her daughter is portrayed by
Judy Greer and she had a very difficult
youth because most of her youth was also
being trained for the inevitable return
of Michael Myers and so she has a lot of
baggage with her mom and they don't
really get along well and I love that
part of the film I loved it but then it
decides to do some other things we'll
talk about in a second Michael Myers is
great in the film he looks cool the mask
is good he doesn't look atrocious Lee
young and small like he did in h2o with
that really clean mask
the look of Michael Myers is great and I
also appreciated that Nick Castle
reprised him in certain scenes and so
that was really nice to see there are a
few callbacks to the first film that
didn't really feel necessarily like just
nostalgia but actually added a unique
twist to the film one in particular in a
classroom early on and one towards the
end which I of course will not spoil but
there are also a lot of kills in the
movie that are sort of almost directly
ripped from other films there's a
bathroom scene that we have seen in the
trailer that is very much so like a
bathroom scene in h2o and there are some
kills that are very much so like the
first film I also like the dynamic
that's explored with will Patton's
character police officer and Jamie Lee
Curtis they meet up for a second and it
seems like they might team up and that's
kind of exciting because there is some
backstory there which you'll see when
you experience the film and I was like
oh that's interesting I really like
where this could go
there are certain scenes that feel
almost like John Carpenter directed them
and then there are other scenes that
feel very much so like David Gordon
Green directed them who up until now has
primarily directed dramas and comedies
and now for the first time in his career
he's directing a full-fledged horror
film and I have to be honest it kind of
shows there are sequences throughout the
movie that feel like a more seasoned
horror director would have seen it a
thousand times and decide not to do that
there's a very elongated creeping
through the house scene that does not
have much suspense let's let's get into
my negatives here because this movie was
very disappointing for me there are
aspects as I said that are so good and
that's what makes some of the other
choices so frustrating
there's a complete lack of atmosphere
here one of the best parts of John
Carpenter's Halloween and really most of
his movies even the not-so-great ones is
he is so good at atmosphere and movies
like trick-or-treat for instance which
my wife are not just reviewed understand
the atmosphere of the holiday and what
it could mean this movie has very little
atmosphere it doesn't really feel like
you get set up it doesn't feel like a
lot of tension is built and so much of
it is diffused by completely misplaced
comedy Danny McBride was a major
creative force behind the film who I
honestly I love eastbound and down
I liked him an alien covenant I think he
is hilarious and an extremely talented
actor but there's a lot of comedy in the
movie that just did not work and when
you feel like you're getting to the
point we might kind of be on edge
there'll be a scene with two cops in a
car joking about their lunch like one
has a very exotic type of baguette
sandwich and he's explaining it and the
other just has a brownie and chocolate
pudding and they had like this whole
scene about that and it's just this most
random misplaced moment there's a lot of
stuff like that in the film as a result
it feels like the movie is unfocused
it's trying to be a horror film that
tributes the original it's trying very
much so to be its own movie and a few
specific plot points I'll get into in a
second without spoiling anything but
it's also trying to be funny
it has Laurie Strode as this badass and
it has her family Judy Greer her
daughter and then Judy Greer's daughter
Laurie's granddaughter and it's just a
lot of people running around and some of
them have no purpose in the film
particularly the granddaughter character
there's just a lot of characters that
are in the film specifically to run away
from Michael Myers and really have
nothing else to add to the film and this
is where the film
it's very frustrating because I loved to
set up with Laurie I loved it I was so
ready for it but it focuses so much on
her granddaughter and a high school
dance and the romantic drama between her
and a boy in a scene that I just saw in
goosebumps too by the way
like the exact scene occurs and there's
so many choices like that built upon the
cliches we are so used to seeing in
these films and I am wondering why all
these years later they've chosen to get
all of these pieces together to make a
sequel to one of the best horror films
ever saying the rest of them don't
matter and they basically do the same
thing again but just sort of shuffle a
few things around and have all these
needless characters in the movie that
don't need to be there the biggest
problem I have with this film involves a
character and a choice towards the start
of the third act that blows my mind it's
a major spoiler and I can't get into it
but it's the type of risk that if it
paid off it would have been very
interesting but it doesn't when the film
ended my friends and I there was like
four of us and we just turned to each
other and we were like what the hell was
spoilers all about and everybody was
just baffled by it it is the strangest
choice that I've seen in a movie like
this in a while I can't believe that
this choice when across as many desks as
it did and got approved as many times as
it did because it's just the most random
thing that actually is instantaneously
thrown away I mean within two minutes I
wish there was more Jamie Lee Curtis she
was so great in the movie and it should
have just been about her I do not need a
high school dance
I don't need random young people who are
talking about getting high and they're
gonna have sex and Michael's gonna kill
them I feel like that entirely is a
demographic choice like well if we're
gonna have another Halloween movie it
has to appeal to young people right well
no it's rated R you got to be like 17 to
see it so what's the point just have it
be entirely Laurie focused but it's not
it
goes away from her far too much and
every time it does it just kind of lost
interest and towards the end that
specific choice I I hinted at was so
strange and out of left field along with
the comedy it just diffused so much of
the tension there wasn't enough
atmosphere either in the end this film
revs to life in spurts there are moments
that I thought were just so good and one
moment towards the end that I loved so
much it gave me chills and that's why
the movie is so frustrating because
there are so many parts of it and I was
like oh my god you understand and then
other choices why why I just sat there
thinking this is is certainly never the
way I would ever approach a movie like
this and it's very strange to me it's
also kind of Terminator 2 in some ways I
mean Laurie Strode is basically Sarah
Connor she encountered a seemingly
unstoppable entity that could not be
killed and just kept coming for her over
and over again and now that she has
escaped this thing she has trained
herself to be a badass and is awaiting
its return and everyone around her
thinks she's insane so I mean I imagine
that may have been the pitch like hey
let's make Laurie Strode Sarah Connor
and Michael Myers is like the Terminator
except he's not good he's bad and you
know we have a new movie also why is it
called Halloween we have three movies
called Halloween now like whenever I
talk about this movie to anybody now I'm
always gonna have to differentiate which
one it is I mean as fans don't we all
say Rob Zombie Halloween none of us say
Halloween when referring to Rob Zombie's
remake we just call it the Rob Zombie
movie
what am I supposed to call this one
20:18 Halloween
I guess they should have called it
Halloween Returns or something like that
I think that was actually the working
title this movie it's okay I'm more
frustrated I think than most I feel like
most people are going to walk into this
movie and leave thinking I was fine it
was okay like or it was really good it
was the best Halloween sequel but I mean
come on when you have movies like curse
of michael myers.slc punk
oh my god that movie I mean obviously
the film is gonna look better when you
compare it to that but to be completely
honest I like Halloween too more than
this one I'm gonna give Halloween 2018
see I encourage you to go see the film
for yourself don't listen to my opinion
or you know a website that aggregates a
score make up your own mind go see it
for yourself because you might like it
more than me
you might like it less than me I don't
know it's I don't really know actually
how fans are gonna react to this because
horror fans are very different than your
average movie fans like some just want
to know about what the kills are like or
what weapons the person uses or what the
mask looks like you know there's certain
horror devices that horror fans really
dig I like all that stuff too but I also
want a compelling narrative you know and
this movie just it was unfocused guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to more reviews very soon
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]